ينضم الينا الان من غلاف غزه مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرام الياس كيف يتفاعل كل
ذلك عوده الاشتباكات الى الشمال بعد ان
كان قال مسؤولون اسرائيليون لمناسبه طي
هذه الحرب 100 يوم ان الاوضاع تقريبا
انتهت في الشمال وايضا كيف يتفاعل اطلاق
الصواريخ دفعات الصواريخ الى البلدات
والمدن
الاسرائيليه
وكاننا نعود ثلاثه اسابيع الى الوراء
حقيقه لان ما يجري الان في منطقه جباليا
وفي الجهه الشرقيه لجبال البلد يعيدنا الى
المعركه الكبيره التي كنا رصدناها قبل
ثلاثه اسابيع من منطقه غلاف غزه التي كانت
عمه جباليا البلد وجباليا المخيم كان
واضحا بان هنالك توغل كما يبدو للدبابات
الاسرائيليه في المناطق الشرقيه لجبال
وكانت هنا هنالك عده قذائف من هذه
الدبابات وجهت صوب منطقه جباليا رافقها
ايضا اشتباكات بالاسلحه الرشاشه الثقيله
وكانت هنالك في الساعه الاخيره غارات جويه
مكثفه على تلك المناطق بعينها ربما تسمعون
التفجيرات التي تاتي من جهه جباليا الان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يبدو انه يواصل العمل في
بعض المناطق هناك على تفجير ال انفاق
الهجوميه التابعه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه على
اعتبار ان بعض التفجيرات
كانت تشير الى ان هنالك ما هو ملغم او ما
تم تلغيمه كما يبدو من انفاق او
منشات وليس انفجارات ناجمه عن غارات جويه
او قصف مدفعي لذلك هنالك تفجيرات حصلت في
الساعه الاخيره في منطقه جباليا ربما تحمل
مؤشرات على ان ال الجيش الاسرائيلي عاد
للعمل في تلك المنطقه بحثا عن مقار او
مستودعات اسلحه او ربما منصات سواريخ او
ربما تكون
اي انفاق هجوميه يبحث عنها ويحاول تفجيرها
لكن الواضح ان المشهد من عندنا هنا كما
ذكرت يذكرنا ب ثلاثه اسابيع الى الوراء
ويعيدنا الى تلك الايام التي كان مخيم
جباليا وجباليا البلد تشهد معارك ضاريه
جدا ما بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الجيش الاسرائيلي هذه المعارك يبدو انها
عادت واشتدت الان ولكن ليس فقط في مخيم
جباليا نحن نرى ايضا غارات
جويه مستمره بين الحين والاخر ايضا على
الشجاعيه على الاطراف الشماليه لمدينه غزه
وكذلك الاطراف الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه جحر
الديك والمخيمات الوسطى لقطاع غزه بمعنى
ان الجبهه كلها ما زالت مشتعله رغم اعلان
الجيش الا الاسرائيلي عن سحب الفرقه 36
بالامس واعلان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي عن
انتهاء العمليات الكبرى في المناطق
الشماليه لقطاع غزه هو قال بصريح العباره
بان المناوره الكبيره في المناطق الشماليه
قد انتهت وان المناوره العسكريه في
المناطق الجنوبيه قريبه من الانتهاء لكن
ما نشاهده هنا هو معارك ضاريه معارك
تعيدنا حتى الى الايام الاولى من الحرب
ومن المعركه البريه ذلك ان بعض الاشتباكات
التي نراها الان في منطقه جباليا تقع على
مقروه من السياج الامني والقصف من جانب
الدبابات الاسرائيليه ياتي من تلك المناطق
باتجاه اي منطقه جباليا واحيانا المناطق
الشماليه لمدينه غزه اي من ناحيه اخرى نحن
نرى ان ليس فقط هنالك اشتباكات ميدانيه
على الارض من جانب المقاومه الفلسطينيه
واشتباك وجها لوجه ربما مع هذه هذه القوات
الاسرائيليه انما المقاومه الفلسطينيه
تبدي قدره ايضا على توجيه ضربات صاروخيه
واحيانا ضربات صاروخيه هائله وكبيره
ومكثفه كما كان عليه الحال صباح هذا اليوم
عندما استهدفت المقاومه الفلسطينيه مدينه
نيتي فوت بدفعه صاروخيه قالت بلديه نيتي
فوت انها اشتملت على 50 صاروخا بعضها تم
اعتراضه من جانب منظومه القبه الحديديه
وبعضه بعض هذه الصواريخ تجاوزت المنظومه
الدفاعيه وسقطت داخل المدين محدثه اصابات
واضرار في بعض المباني وكذلك في بعض
البلدات المحيطه في نتيفوت كاس دوت نجف
وجف عوليم التي سقطت فيها بعض الصواريخ
واحدثت اضرارا في البنى التحتيه لذلك هذه
هذا القصف الصاروخي اليوم كان يحمل حقيقه
رسائل سياسيه من جانب المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وان بوسائل قتاليه ذلك انه تزامن مع
اجتماع المجلس الحربي مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي مع رؤساء البلدات الاسرائيليات
والذي كان يهدف هذا الاجتماع الى مناقشه
مساله احتمال عوده او اعاده الاسرائيليين
الى بلداتهم في منطقه غلاف غزه لكن
التصريح الذي صدر من جانب رئيس الوزراء
بنيمين نتنياهو في اعقاب هذا الاجتماع وفي
اعقاب هذه الدفعه الصاروخيه ان اعاده
الاسرائيليين الى بلداتهم لن يكون ممكنا
الا بعد القضاء على حركه حماس وهذا الموقف
كان عبر عنه حقيقه رؤساء السلطات الحليه
هنا في منطقه غلاف غزه على مدى الاسابيع
الماضيه حيث كانوا متوجس
ومتشكر العوده لانهم كانوا يرون بان ال
العمليه العسكريه لم تاتي بنتائج ملموسه
على الارض ولم توقف اطلاق الصواريخ ولا
قذائف الهون على البلدات الاسرائيليه وعلى
المناطق القريبه من البلدات الاسرائيليه
في منطقه الغلاف لذلك هم كانوا يرفضون كل
الدعوات التي اتت من جانب الحكومه
الاسرائيليه للعوده الى منازلهم والى
مواقعهم في منطقه الغلاف الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تريد ان تزيل عن كاهلها
بطبيعه الحال ثقلا كبيرا من ناحيه
اقتصاديه على اعتبار انها تمول نحو 60,000
اسرائيلي تمول اقامتهم في الفنادق وفي دور
الضيافه وتدفع ادويتهم ومستلزماتهم وكل ما
يحتاجونه من من تعويضات في هذا السياق لكن
واضح بان الوضع الامني لا يمكن للحكومه
الاسرائيليه باعاده الاسرائيليين
والاسرائيليين انفسهم هم متوجس من مساله
العوده الى منازلهم على ضوء استمرار القصف
الصاروخي وهذا التصاعد في القتال من جديد
على اكثر من جهه وعلى اكثر من محور هنا في
قطاع غزه اشكرك الياس كرام مراسلنا من
غلاف غزه